let's just stick in Florida a little bit
because I am curious what's going on
let's go to David in Florida David
welcome
David if this is me it is you
cool I love the show I just wanted to
have a question something that was on my
brain a while ago okay um you would ask
a lot of the Republican or more trumpian
Republican side if they can answer the
simple question of you know who's the
president
now my thought was isn't that a
citizenship question if you can answer
who the president is I'm not saying to
take away citizenship as the final
result but if they can't answer a simple
question you know what are we doing here
that's a good question I don't know uh
let's see U.S citizenship questions and
answers
um I don't know if who is the current
President is on there it very well may
be
uh name your representative name your
Senator seems to be on there I don't see
who is the president let me see oh no
what is the name of the president of the
United States yeah that's true well
listen I don't think it'll come as a
shock to you that lots of people who got
citizenship by birth could not actually
pass the citizenship test in the United
States I mean we we used to do like men
on the street stuff where I would ask
people who's your Senator or name any
Senator and tons of people wouldn't
wouldn't get those answers right so this
goes back to the thing I was talking
about with Tamisha about you know
probably 80 percent of people are sort
of like incompetent to some degree
unfortunately I I'm gonna have to agree
with you on that one yeah but uh I'll
I'll relieve any of the any uh extra
time I have to someone else from Florida
okay well I don't have anyone else what
what part of Florida are you in
um down in Fort Lauderdale about an hour
north of Miami oh okay yeah that's not a
that's not a bad area I mean listen if I
had to live in Florida which I'm to be
totally Frank it's not out of the
possibility that I would in the future
spend significant time in Florida I
would be in one of two places I would
either be in the Miami area or I would
be in Pensacola which I know sounds
weird it's like the Panhandle you know
but we've got some great friends up
there and you know there's a Jew or two
in Pensacola it's not just waspy
I of the two I would have to say uh
Pensacola would be uh the better choice
you can probably get a little bit more
land uh it's probably a little bit
quieter down in Miami I'm looking at
dinner tonight and trying to make a
reservation the reservation said you
have to spend a hundred dollars per
guest so oh is that right what
restaurant is that
this was uh sugar it's a just a nice
view of Miami with some seafood
um I wanted to do something a little
nice but maybe not 200 nice yeah yeah
hey have you been to mandolin Aegean
Bistro
I have not I'm gonna have to look that
one up though that's a hot place if you
can get in there I love it there
I appreciate it thank you okay thanks
for the call appreciate it there's David
from Florida we're gonna take the
quickest of quick breaks if you're
holding don't go anywhere because I'm
going right back to the phones in a
moment all of us have had the experience
of dropping out of an important Zoom
call because of a flaky Wi-Fi connection
I've had it when live streaming if you
can think of something more humiliating
let me know uh something else I struggle
with is when I'm on the go finding a
good enough connection to upload or
download large video files which I
regularly need to do what if you could
fix all of this by using more than one
internet connection at the same time
like the coffee shop Wi-Fi and your
mobile phones connection combining them
into one super internet connection
that's faster and more reliable our
sponsor speedify is the only app that
can combine multiple internet sources
into one fantastic super connection like
this this will improve your live
streaming your video calling your gaming
the web browsing everything you do
online use speedify on all devices PC
Mac iPhone Android Linux works with any
type of internet connection simple to
use runs in the background I use it
everywhere especially when traveling and
it works great try speedify risk free
for seven days and get 20 off go to
speedify.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman click the link down in the
description